des images de fou ça cartonner
d’ailleurs sur M6 hier le titre de
l’enquête ultra-droite et groupe
néo-nazi la nouvelle menace terroriste
avec la mouvance de l'ultra-droite qui
s'est radicalisé pendant le confinement
les défenseurs de la race blanche ou
encore les nationalistes extrêmes
certains vont très loin ils passent
parfois à l'acte en commettant le pire
et puisque l'enquête collée à l'actu en
France 5 rassemblements ultra droite ont
été interdits à Paris en vous le savez
il y a quelques jours par notre ministre
de l'Intérieur l'affaire a pris un
tournant politique cette semaine
regardez
près de 600 militants du comité du 9 mai
un gros plus cule d'ultra-droite on
défilé en mémoire de Sébastien des yeux
un militant mort accidentellement en
1994 alors qu'il tentait d'échapper à la
police pour la première fois le
rassemblement a attiré des militants
venus de toute la France et ils étaient
plus nombreux que d'habitude dans leurs
mains des drapeaux ornés de croix
celtiques symbole de la suprématie de la
race blanche tolérée par la préfecture
le rassemblement qui a lieu chaque année
composé majorité d'activistes cagoulés a
fait polémique jusque dans l’hémicycle
le ministre de l'Intérieur a demandé au
préfet d'interdire désormais ce genre de
rassemblement
ils sont connus il y en a 3000 en France
dont mille fichiers S mais c'est vrai
que là il y a une polémique sur la
manifestation n'oublions pas quand même
que cette manifestation a permis de les
fichiers de les cibler de se renseigner
sur eux c'est pour ça qu'à l'origine
elle avait été permise
de renseignement de travailler de les
identifier alors l'enquête a montré
qu'il existe dans notre pays des
milliers de forums de suprématistes
blancs et qui ont des sujets de
conversation peu classique
après plusieurs semaines d'enquête nous
identifions ce forum néonazi francophone
premier choc le nombre d'inscrits 3600
personnes et 300 000 échanges le racisme
au quotidien
raciologie au quotidien les 3600
inscrits communiquent sous pseudonyme
exclusivement
et doivent respecter cette règle ne
jamais échanger de données personnelles
nous découvrons aussi ce site de vente
en libre accès à travers le monde des
souvenirs du Troisième Reich décoration
militaire grade pièce d'identité de
Waffen SS carte postale de propagande
mise à prix total de la collection 44000
euros
ça rappelle à quel point le devoir de
mémoire il est primordial dans
l'éducation de nos enfants et pour les
prochaines générations enfin les cours
d'histoire surtout vos enfants faut
qu'ils les suivre parce que là c'est une
génération qui oublie le passé comment
on peut encore s'amuser et glorifier une
époque mais mais juste dégueulasse quoi
ça me paraît ça me paraît fou qui est
3000 personnes sur sur des sites comme
ça et beaucoup d'autres on peut pas bien
mais c'est la bonne question super
malins en fait ils savent contourner les
lois ils savent exactement ce qu'ils
peuvent dire pas dire ils se montrent
pas en France par exemple vous pouvez
pas exhiber un insigne nazi et ben ils
le font pas vous voyez ils ils sont
malins et en fait les autorités
n'arrivent pas à les faire condamner
parce qu'il contourne alors les sites
qui réunissent les suprémacistes et les
racistes cartonnent tellement le nombre
d'inscrits ne cesse d'augmenter et ils
ont maintenant leur propre site de
rencontre voilà c'est vrai qu'il y a un
site de rencontre qui est dédié à ça et
rien que les pseudos des gens regardez
c'est c'est c'est chelou
leurs vidéos de propagande célèbre
l'amour exclusivement entre blanc
avec des enfants blancs et une mère
soumise à son mari une vie blanche
un amour blanc au moment de notre
inscription le site compte 6221
utilisateurs et profils explicites
arianoid en référence à la race aryenne
avec en signature une croix gammée un
autre a recouvert l'Europe de l'étang
d'arnasie
la couleur l'amour blanc l'amour c'est
un racisme absolu là franchement je
comprends pas qu'on puisse accéder à de
tel site en France et dans le même
comparable qu'avec le terrorisme
islamique ou c'est voilà c'est du
terroriste ça peut se transformer
d'ailleurs il en parle
les équipes donc il y a du vivant on
peut interroger un homme qui se
revendiquer comme néo-nazi qui a purgé
sa peine depuis mais qui raconte la
manière dont il propage son idéologie
regarde
un petit peu perdue et voilà j'ai
rencontré les personnes qui avaient une
idéologie voilà je suis tombé dedans
j'ai eu le moment que j'étais de plus en
plus dans ce milieu là c'est à dire le
milieu
extrémiste entre guillemets j'ai
considéré qu'il était impossible pour
moi de te côtoyer des personnes
d'origine
étrangères quand j'étais en prison j'ai
propagé mon idéologie peut-on avoir
sortir j'étais vraiment assez prosélyte
et prosélyte elle veut qu'on dit
généralement politique
ça va ramener des gens dans notre cause
dans notre milieu fais rentrer les gens
dans l'armée dans la police dans la
pénitentiaire et petit à petit distiller
notre idéologie c'est comme ça que je
dis c'est vraiment c'est masqué après
nous nous allons revenir
il dit un truc qu'on entend souvent
d'ailleurs même chez vous parlez parler
de terrorisme tout à l'heure c'est vrai
j'étais un petit peu perdu et c'est vrai
que on sert beaucoup il sert beaucoup de
ça de personnes un petit peu perdu qui
savent pas trop où aller qui savent pas
trop ils en sont pour essayer de leur
donner voilà il leur dit souvent vous
allez entrer dans une famille voilà tu
étais tout seul peut-être tu as pas de
famille tu as pas de voilà donc c'est ça
va être comme il a dit on m'a fait
rentrer dans une idéologie on m'a en
fait ils ont créé et créer une vie et
c'est ça et c'est pour ça que comme je
vous dis voilà il y a de plus en plus de
gens voilà qui sont aussi perdus voilà
et on le voit et comme il a dit moi
j'étais un petit peu perdu et c'est ça
qui les amène à faire des conneries et à
se tourner vers les extrêmes vers des
groupes muscules et c'est vrai que voilà
c'est c'est aujourd'hui comme disait on
parlait tout à l'heure mais c'est vrai
que là il faut aider il faut aider les
Français il faut que le gouvernement se
bouge et qu'il faut qu'il aide les
Français et il faut que les Français
s'entendaient il faut que les Français
ne soient plus perdus moi je vois de
plus en plus de Français qui me disent
je suis perdu parce que ils s'en sortent
pas financièrement parce que ils sont
seuls parce qu'ils sont pas parce qu'ils
sont abandonnés et forcément après bah
ça donne des situations comme celle-ci
et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui il y a
urgence voilà on le sait et ça c'est
important de dire ça parce que c'est ça
c'est ça résume en fait tout ce qui se
passe actuellement plein de gens voilà
qui sont perdus quand on est perdu on
fait des conneries et quand on est perdu
on se tourne vers vers des des solutions
qui sont forcément pas toujours les
bonnes on va montrer une autre image
c'est les journalistes de l'émission
peut rencontrer aussi un de ses amis à
ce jeune homme qui se fait appeler
Captain regardez
alors moi je suis capable j'ai quand
même deux ans et je viens du nord de
l'Alsace et nationaliste nous installons
son micro et sous sa veste une arme à
feu
préfère sortir en toute sécurité
j'aurais préféré que vous ne le sachiez
pas mais bon c'est vraiment pas des
défenses quoi moi même je me vois un
petit peu comme un recruteur dans ce
milieu là par exemple lors d'une soirée
je suis amené à rencontrer des gens
discuter une chose en une autre on a
reçu un sujet on en discute je vais leur
donner une force de miroir des gens qui
partagent la même idée que un groupe
avec lequel il faut pouvoir se réunir
tout simplement
qu'est-ce que vous disiez la notion de
groupe exactement
intéressé à une jeune fille ur de
l'extrémisme d'ultra droite et qui a
voulu passer des mots aux actes qui
s'appelle Logan
il a seulement 25 ans il avait planifié
de nombreux attentats terroristes avant
d'être interpellés au domicile de sa
mère regardez le leader et l'uniquement
du groupe à être maintenu en détention
il s'appelle Logan nizain 25 ans il a
avoué ses projets d'action terroristes
pour refaire la France comme il le dit
ni un veut passer à l'action il tente de
se procurer des armes sur l'un des Sites
néo-nazis les plus dangereux et actifs
au monde nous retrouvons ces échanges si
je peux trouver un tel matériel le futur
de la France sera changé pour un
ak-47000 euros c'est trop cher mais je
les prends pour 600 ou 700 euros
quelques heures plus tard le raid
intervient dans l'appartement de sa mère
Niza était condamné à 9 ans de prison
lui et ses complices ont été stoppés
dans leur projet terroriste alors ils
ont eu
l'organisant au téléphone il a été
contacté par enquête exclusive il avoue
toutes les choses qui étaient prêts à
faire pour mettre en pratique son
idéologie écoutez
pourra y jouer à la belote comme disait
le Maestra nous on était prêt à aller à
tuer des gens nous on avait pensé à
faire exploser des mosquées on avait
pensé à acquérir des arbres par divers
moyens pour tuer des personnes ça tirer
sur les principaux drogue on avait pensé
à tient aujourd'hui un discours de
repenti
et moi je veux dire quand même à tous
ces gens
de passer au terrorisme ne le faites pas
ne le faites pas la grande question des
autorités c'est ce que ce repentir est
sincère ou pas
voilà après moi je trouve qu'aujourd'hui
il y a deux choses il y a l'ultra gauche
et l'ultra droite ultra gauche
pardonnez-moi mais c'est pas des
questions de pouvoir d'achat quand ils
vont casser c'est souvent des fils de
bourgeois qui veulent se donner un petit
frisson comme ça en disant on va rentrer
à l'Élysée on va couper des têtes on va
défoncer les banquiers on va prendre au
super riche et c'est pas des gens qui
ont des pouvoirs des problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat ils nous ont parlé
d'ailleurs la dernière fois le les
policiers qui étaient venus il me disait
qu'il y a une nouvelle un nouveau style
ils appellent ça les les bourgeois black
boxe
et illustratoire en fait quand on l'a vu
dans le reportage c'est aussi
pardonnez-moi mais c'est juste un
racisme absolu quoi c'est des gens qui
sont juste obsédés par la race blanche
qui veulent juste tuer des Noirs tuer
des Arabes enfin c'est c'est tuer les
Juifs enfin c'est juste hallucinant et
pardonnez-moi mais dans leur
revendications alors peut-être qu'ils
sont perdus pour des raisons économiques
mais moi je trouve que c'est pas ça
c'est vraiment une sorte de de folie
racialiste tu penses qu'on peut trouver
sur Internet des groupuscules d'extra
d'extrême gauche qui vont qui vont avoir
des propos aussi
violents dramatiques par les tueries ou
quoi que ce soit parce que tu as fait un
parallèle entre l'extrême pour moi c'est
tout aussi catastrophe
non plus on peut pas mettre un signe
égal c'est pas parce que regarde la
preuve ça c'est le genre de truc que tu
vas dans les reportages américains et en
fait tu te rends compte que ça existe en
France ça se trouve il y a des choses
mais pas au courant et c'est pour ça que
moi je trouve qu'ils ont eu raison
justement parce que moi j'étais un peu
choqué que ce soit autorisé ce truc là
dans Paris mais au final je me rends
compte que ils avaient peut-être raison
parce que au moins on voit ce truc là au
grand jour et comme disait Gilles vont
peut-être pouvoir combattre ces choses
là donc peut-être que ça existe on sait
pas l'histoire nous apprend quand même
que ces groupuscules existent depuis
très longtemps
justement de cette révolution là mais là
aujourd'hui je pense que le vrai danger
il est plutôt de ce côté-là je pense que
le vrai dangereux
il est partout il est partout